now let's bring in washington post
national correspondent phillip bump for
more on this philip good morning good
morning so the president's kind of
caught between two sides even within his
own party here
what does he do
uh it's a great question we'll find out
on tuesday but i mean i think the the
challenge that trump faces at this point
is that he ran his campaign on an
immigration platform that lacked any
nuance it was we're going to take a hard
line on immigration for on immigrants
that are here illegally and now he's in
a position where as president he needs
to figure out if there is a nuanced path
forward here his party's pushing him
obviously democrats agree with uh
president obama's initial decision and
so it'll be interesting to see how he
resolves it anthony mentioned he's
between sort of two places even within
his own party how much blowback does he
face well this is a great question
because the reason that donald trump is
president is in part because of his hard
line on immigration he got this huge
base of support right at the beginning
of the primaries as a result of that and
his base believes in this issue but his
base also loves him basically no matter
what he does as we've seen repeatedly in
polling so it'll be interesting to see
if he does buck them on daca if they
will actually still stand by him
meanwhile the republican-led congress
comes back from the summer break next
week
um they haven't been able to agree on
much but at the top of the agenda now is
going to be this is heart relief for
harvey right is is that going to get
through it seems like it i mean this is
obviously people are always supportive
of taking steps to help after natural
disaster even the folks who are sort of
reticent in the wake of hurricane sandy
which happened to be a lot of folks from
texas and in fact i have already said
this chris christie has been pointing
out repeatedly right that's correct uh
so it seems like this will get through
this seems like one of the sorts of
things that congress even in its sort of
impaired state can get done despite
having republican control we've seen so
much gridlock there and it was not bad
from senator john mccain about getting
past that gridlock this week
are they at the point where they have to
get past that gridlock
well yeah i mean if they want to get
anything done i mean the thing to keep
in mind though is that the gridlock that
we're seeing in washington is not
entirely the sort of thing we've seen in
the past for its republicans and
democrats and loggerheads essentially
there are two factions in the republican
party as we keep talking about and if we
look at the health care bill for example
the problem was not that democrats were
oppositional it was that moderate
republicans and conservative republicans
couldn't agree and so there certainly is
something to be resolved but at this
point it's mostly within the republican
party i want to turn to the russia
investigation for a moment because there
are reports in your newspaper in the new
york times that special counsel robert
mueller's team
is now in possession of an early draft
of the letter by president trump and top
aide stephen miller which laid out the
case for firing fbi director james comey
how significant is this letter
until we see it it's hard to say but
it's potentially very significant i mean
one of the questions at hand that robert
mueller is apparently investigating is
whether or not donald trump obstructed
justice by firing jim comey the fbi
director and one thing that will tell us
whether or not he obstructed justice is
what he was thinking was he thinking
about the russia investigation was he
trying to impede that this letter which
apparently is multiple pages long the
new york times said that it was
essentially a screed which suggested it
was had a lot of emotion in it if that
letter suggests that donald trump was
prepared to tell james comey it was
because of the russian investigation
that certainly bolsters the idea that he
was trying to prevent the russia
investigation from moving forward we've
also learned that mueller's enlisted the
irs's criminal investigation unit to
help in his investigation what does that
tell us well i think people sort of they
hear this robert mueller is
investigating russia and it's it's sort
of like if you have a break-in at your
house and the police come over and they
see a dead body on the floor they're
going to ask you about that dead body
and so robert mueller is sort of in this
investigation and it seems as though
he's pulling in some other finance
related stuff the daily beast reports
the irs is getting looped into this
which suggests maybe there's some tax
related issues so there's a lot of
things we don't really know what the
scope of this is yet but it's pretty
clear it's not solely related on focus
on russia all right phillip national
correspondent for the washington post
thanks for being with us